greetings everybody and my name is david
rosenberg and it's my pleasure to
actually do the welcome and the
introduction professor chiron skinner
was called away at the last minute and
and so i'm going to combine those two
functions I can't welcome you on behalf
of Carnegie Mellon University but I can
say how very grateful the Pittsburgh
Darfur emergency coalition is to
Carnegie Mellon University for hosting
this wonderful conference they've been
extremely generous and I think vice
associate vice president tim McNulty is
especially to be thanked for his his
timely support on your program to are
also the sponsors and co sponsors of
this event not going to read all the
co-sponsors we had a number of churches
and student groups who contributed to
the expenses of this conference i
specially note the Save Darfur coalition
the national safe dark for coalition
who's barely former president Gerry
Fowler is here today provided a initial
grant to get us started with the
conference Global Solutions Pittsburgh
which is part of a national organization
also with headquarters downtown and
pittsburgh has also been supportive of
our pittsburgh coalition for this for
five of the six years that we've been in
business and i especially like to also
thank the Sudanese community in
Pittsburgh Benedict kulang and Isaac
Lazoo loading the Sudanese community
here has been extremely generous a
number of the number of ways and
supportive of our advocacy for Darfur
but in connection with the conference
there hope they're hosting many of the
Diaspora guests here
we only had to put up a limited number
of our many guests in hotel rooms and
that's because of the welcoming arms of
the Sudanese community in Pittsburgh so
many thanks many thanks to them and I
also thank them and especially members
of the Diaspora who came to Pittsburgh
in October of this past year for a
planning meeting for this larger
conference which was held at Chatham
University all right well that said I
would like to just I guess mentioned
briefly this this fact that the pure
audio program as you know the this has
been a conference for the Sudanese
diaspora and they've been conferring
very very vigorously and and engagingly
all day today and they're going to bring
their conclusions to this this
conference on after general Gration
speaks today and the two representatives
that were chosen by the Diaspora
drafting committee for this function our
professor Laura Ben was sitting in the
front row laura is a lawyer and
economist she's on the faculty of the
university of michigan law school she's
a Sudanese American and she's a partner
in the peace dividend limited which is
an initiative to support South Sudanese
entrepreneurs next to laura is me Ahmad
Ahmadi person who's come to Pittsburgh
several times and is well known in the
activist community she's a dar for human
rights activist and advocate she's the
founder of Darfur women's Action Group
and she's a member of the for solidarity
alliance Solidarity of North America
which represents 17 states looking for
peace and justice in homeland
so those two are not included in your
program because they were just selected
within the past hour to represent the
Diaspora consensus I want to say one
word about excuse me about why this
conference came about we've been doing
advocacy in Pittsburgh the Pittsburgh
Darfur emergency coalition for almost
six years I have to salute I'd not have
to but I willingly enthusiastically
salute my colleagues from the Pittsburgh
Darfur emergency coalition we've done
all kinds of things we've done marches
we've done rallies we've gone to
Washington five times and to New York
City once in support of National Darfur
actions we collected over 30,000
postcards addressed to both President
Obama and President Bush before him and
but here we are in 2010 and the
emergency that was the cause of our
coming together continues on and has
become even more complex with the
introduction of the South Sudan timeline
that's associated with the comprehensive
peace agreement so it's become apparent
in other words that in order for us to
pursue Darfur advocacy in the mini we
put way we have to expand just to the
same degree that the US policy is come
to engage more than Darfur and is now
engaging south deadlines and issues
related to South Sudan so it's out of a
desire on the part of us as advocates to
learn from the Diaspora to to provide
new inspiration and new guidance about
our own directions that we pursued this
particular conference otherwise you
could say why do I move to be in
Pittsburgh it's in Pittsburgh because
we're at the stage in our coalition
right now but we need to learn
we hope to learn both from the Diaspora
and from general Gration here today to
really tell us something about and
explain US policy under the Obama
administration so with that said you now
receive cards that have been passed
around these cards are for your right
for you to write questions down at the
end of the the presentations today
somebody will collect questions that you
may have written and general basis agree
or very kindly to respond to those
questions I'm not going to read the
introductions to the various speakers
here they're either paragraphs about
them are are printed on in your program
so I'll just really basically tell you
that the format is will ever hear from
Jerry Fowler leading advocate for save
darfur and recently stepped down as
president will hear from the Honorable
Ezekiel love that quote some be an
admission of the government of South
Sudan mission to the United States and
then we'll hear from general Grayson and
then we'll hear from Laura Benanti Ahmad
Ahmadi and then we'll have our
question-and-answer session so Jerry I'd
like to first call you up to the podium
Jerry Fowler has been to Pittsburgh
several times and as recently we
disturbed one year ago that you were
here for 33 unforgettable days where we
worked or Gary before thousands of audie
house ins of students and he did a
wonderful job in inspiring our community
so we please just come up in the order
that I've just mentioned Jerry and
honorable Ezekiel got quote and General
Scott creation pender Laura and name
thank you David thanks for inviting me
and invited me to say a few words I'll
be very brief I think most people who
are here will be very anxious to hear
above what Ezekiel and general Grayson
have to say and then to hear from the
result of the deliberations of the
Diaspora I was asked to say a few words
about the prospects for peace in Darfur
which I'm happy to do and I was going to
touch basically on on for general areas
the first being security the second
being the political foundation for peace
in Darfur the third being the economic
foundation for peace in Darfur and the
fourth being the international role
before doing that though one thing that
I want to to note and to emphasize and
it picks up on something that that you
said David which is the idea that the
prospects for peace in Darfur cannot be
separated from the prospects for peace
in Sudan as a whole and that resolving
the issues in Darfur cannot be done
without resolving resolving the issues
in Sudan as a whole and vice versa and
in particular the broader issues of
Sudan are issues of marginalization and
exclusion and that has to be dealt with
throughout the whole country or as may
be the case within a year countries that
constitutes Sudan right now and any
attempt to focus on Darfur to the
exclusion of the larger issues would
frustrate efforts to bring about peace
and vice versa a second broad
observation that I would make and
general Grayson may have more to say
about this but I'm very very skeptical
that the elections that are scheduled
for next month will go very far towards
addressing these issues
marginalization and exclusion it is not
the case that the or I would not argue
that the elections shouldn't happen I
think that they can serve some positive
purposes but they will not resolve these
issues of marginalization and exclusion
and there are two particular reasons
that I would cite if I had more time I
would go into greater detail the first
is that even at the center where there's
the most amount of political activity
happening so in in the non River Valley
the political space is very very limited
and one just example of that within the
last couple of weeks was that one of the
most prominent candidates for president
Sadiq almaty who was the Prime Minister
democratically elected prime minister
who was overthrown by the current
government in 1989 was going to give a
radio address and he was blocked from
giving that radio address on state
controlled radio because among other
things it mentioned the International
Criminal Court indictment of omar bashir
and in a whole lot of ways they don't
have time to to detail the the political
space is is very limited and I think
that assuming that the elections go
forward in April one thing that everyone
will have to pay attention to whether
its members of the Diaspora or or
members of the international community
and certainly people in Sudan is whether
this limited space that's available is
allowed to continue to exist and be
expanded by activists and by political
actors inside Sudan or or is it shut
down the second point with regard to to
the elections that I would point out is
in particular with regard to Darfur is
it doesn't seem to me that the
conditions for any kind of meaningful
elections in Darfur exist today or will
exist in the next 30 days by april
eleventh just one particular thing quite
and i'll talk about security in just a
second as i said security is an issue
regarded the elections but also the fact
that for the most part the displaced
population which numbers in the millions
the UN estimate is 2.7 million by and
large did not register for the elections
so they won't be participating in that
sense they've been disenfranchised so so
just by definition the ability of the
elections in Darfur to address issues of
marginalization exclusion with such a
large portion of the population excluded
from the process means that that the
elections really cannot resolve anything
or even I think in Darfur be a step
forward with those preliminary marks out
remarks out of the way and realizing
that most of my time is probably already
gone I touch very briefly on four big
issues that are relevant to the
prospects for peace and Sudan the first
is security I had the opportunity to go
to Sudan last month which is actually in
spite of having been working on Sudan
for 10 years the first time that the
government has actually given me
permission to go and I acknowledge the
fact that they gave me permission to go
so in that sense I mean to accept
anything I do is step forward or a step
backward it was good that they that they
allowed someone like myself who has been
a very strong critic of the government
to come and one of the things that we
said to government officials at the end
of our trip was that that they should
continue to allow outsiders to come to
Darfur this access has been an issue and
to have one relatively brief trip by an
organization such as myself is is not
enough there should be a continual
opening of Darfur and the rest of Sudan
to to reporting groups such as Human
Rights Watch refugees international
groups that do do reporting on the
humanitarian and human rights situations
but one of the things that we heard
everywhere we went in Dar
for was concerned about security and
that was particularly marked with regard
to the displaced population displace
people live in a tremendous amount of
fear they reported being sometimes
subject to violence inside the camps
they almost all reported to being
subject to violence when they leave
their camps and the primary reason that
they cited for not returning to where
they came from was that it was not safe
interestingly one of the things that we
heard from many of the from government
officials in Khartoum is that people
have returned to their villages in fact
the government gave us a piece of paper
that said that over a million people
have returned to their villages and
there were only two hundred thousand
displaced still in Darfur on the ground
in Darfur we couldn't find any evidence
of that and in talking in particular to
UN officials it's very clear that while
there may have been a trickle of returns
people who have returned to their
villages and there's been some seasonal
migration of people living leaving IDP
camps to do agriculture in the rainy
season they've come back and other than
that most people are still in the IDP
camps and a huge issue that's going to
have to be resolved is regularizing the
situation of IDPs giving them
opportunities either to return to their
villages if that's what they choose to
do or integrating into the places where
they are but none of that is really
possible in the absence of security and
then of course just as we were there and
just as we were leaving the government
launched a major offensive in the jebel
marra area now while it's the case that
there's not organized fighting in in
most of Darfur today this offensive in
jebel marra by all accounts was
incredibly intense and incredibly
violent and particularly had
a very negative effect on civilians and
I think the most disturbing part of that
apart from the immediate cost to
civilians is what that says about the
government's commitment to the safety of
civilians which is to say they don't
have a commitment to the safety of
civilians any more than they have in the
past so it was very disturbing in that
regard but security has got to be dealt
with in order for there to be peace in
Sudan and I'm talking in particular
quite apart from offensive offensives
against the little amount of territory
that still held by rebels but security
in areas that have been under government
control for several years now that is
where it's dangerous that is where a lot
of armed groups including armed groups
that were previously acting as malicious
for the government are causing a
tremendous amount of havoc in endanger
the second point I would touch on is the
political foundation for peace which has
not been built I referenced the fact
that for the elections that are
scheduled for next month that the IDPs
primarily will more or less will be
disenfranchised because they've not
participated in the process and in
general quite apart from their
participation in the electoral process
what we found in talking to a DPS was a
tremendous amount of alienation from the
government not surprisingly because it
was the government and militias allied
with the government that displaced them
in the first place and we could find
very little evidence of any efforts
serious efforts by the government to
reach out to IDPs to create any kind of
dialogue or communication people were
fearful they were distrustful and they
were there marginalization which was the
cause of the violence in the first place
only deepened other issues in terms of a
political foundation for peace that will
have to be addressed our conflict among
communities in Darfur again this is the
type of role that the government should
be playing but in Darfur it historically
has not played and in fact has done the
opposite successor baited conflict among
communities and today it is but I in
large not playing the role of managing
conflict among communities and in the
final issue politically which also leads
into the next issue which is economic
foundation is the issue of land the
issue of land obviously was part of the
local conflict in Darfur those issues
have only become more complicated in the
last few years people who have been
displaced from the land still have a
claim to it and in some cases that lands
been occupied by outsiders that's got to
be dealt with and in general the
availability of land and land tenure has
to be addressed in order for there to be
a political foundation for peace it will
also have to be addressed in order for
there to be an economic foundation of
for peace and on the economic question
the two things that I would just
highlight our number one that in the
immediate sense there needs to be
unemployed herion access to the civilian
population in Darfur although the worst
potential for disaster that that could
have happened with the expulsion a year
ago of humanitarian organizations has
not happened in part because of heroic
efforts by UN agencies and by the egg
groups that were still there the
humanitarian operation providing
immediate relief still seems quite
rickety and that's in part exacerbated
by by difficulties of access in some
ways the government has reduced some of
the obstacles to humanitarian access but
there's not unimpeded humanitarian
access beyond the immediate humanitarian
needs there is a need to start to build
the foundation for development and to
use resources in order to
to create as I said economic foundation
for a future peace in that development
assistance though and and creating that
economic foundation cannot be separated
from creating the political foundation
it's not something that can be figured
out in cartoon or figured out in Cairo
where there's a donors conference that's
happening I guess starting tomorrow but
it's got to be at to include
consultation and involvement from the
population that's on the ground and so
hand-in-hand the political and the
economic foundations for peace have to
be constructed the final thing I'll
touch on very briefly is an
international role I think it's very
important to be clear that there is an
international role in Sudan and what it
is is to help create a space for
Sudanese to resolve the issues of Sudan
without the use of extreme violence
against civilians it's that extreme
violence against civilians which has
been used over the course of the last 20
years in particular that is riveted
worldwide attention on Sudan and it's
the reason why there is an active group
in Pittsburgh and other places in the
United States and in countries all over
the world they care about what's
happening in Sudan so use of extreme
violence against civilians and the role
of the international community in
individual countries like the United
States is to promote a space in which
the issues that I've alluded to
particularly issues of marginalization
and exclusion can be resolved without
the use of extreme violence in that
regard the good news is that there is a
lot of international attention and
international involvement in Sudan the
less good news is that there's a
proliferation of international efforts
that it seemed to me are not always
working together there's the efforts of
general gration and other special envoys
of which there are a large number now
there's the efforts of former South
African president thabo and Becky who
has an African you
mandate to address now all of the issues
of Sudan there's a the head of unamid a
very well-known African diplomat native
Ibrahim named Ibrahim ghanbari who has a
UN in African Union mandate for Darfur
there's a fellow named gibril bassel a
who has a UN and African Union mandate
for peace in Darfur there's another
international diplomat who has a UN
mandate for north-south issues even just
to describe them you can realize what a
proliferation of efforts there are and
there needs to be a unity of effort as
long as there's just a proliferation of
efforts all kind of working without
serious coordination with the others the
ability of the international community
to to be effective in creating that
space that I was talking about for
Sudanese to resolve Sudan's issues will
be extremely limited well that was a
very quick survey of the prospects for
peace to look forward to hearing from
the other speakers
I will be easily by diversity but what
you are talking about salinities very
difficult to be everything but a lot of
issues concerning that is a complex
talking nowaday us may countries in the
world but our try my best thank you very
much David Rosenberg and also the
University here for organizing this
trend very important for us sue beliefs
to come together and see what we can do
about our country I'm also happy to see
good friend general aggression we just
came back from Sudan how long ago two
days ago yes so I'm sure he came last
month if the latest see what
as I told you before run is a complex
issue it has a very long issue than a
messy one you haven't realized by many
countries united kingdom with the turkey
with the Egyptians were there also the
large coolers were unglue Egyptian
condominium eighty ninety nine and ten
when they have decided to go back elin
hand over Sudan Sudanese 9856 but
basically Sudan is the lightest country
in Africa the reach of resources
population is very small estimate is 42
millions people so a big land less
numbers people leading that so we have a
lot of resources to go to now before
suddenly comes independence in 1956 the
voice would understand cover has been
covering us two countries nor for the
south the bridge actually to use a law
called close district ordinance it's
basically a go of that divided the
country into for you to go to the north
have to have a visa but by then it was
called the patch order to cross from the
same with an organist and has been
divided when they decided to go then
they wanted to merge the or an excel
south to the north but it's all that has
resisted
they said no no part of the of the north
because the way they're looking here
they were looking at the North it is
pretty much they are Islamic culture and
we because I'm tired the south we
consider ourselves a while East African
communities really were better off being
next to you can now okay but of course
that they made up their mind in 1956
Rhonda came in the balance right before
that in 1955 dissolve the bed the same
be on a party to Sudan forth for 55
years of attitude that was an agreement
signed in Addis Ababa that agreement was
meant well transitional period of ten
years deceives solids renews came upon
us who don't know they can succeed and
have the own independent state that a
freeman was common friend immunity
comment then President of Sudan say well
this agreement is not a Bible or crime
it was for us into the marina so the war
ii started in nineteen eighty-three
ungentle vomited fire so if you look at
it basically Sudan has been at war with
itself eighty percent of the time we
have been fighting one another so you
know this is the war i participated in
1985 as a young boy I was very young by
Del even though I didn't know when I was
born is culturally
no you can guess how old I am in that
agreement that we have signed parcel
Kenya 2005 it was meant to address two
issues because the definition of Sudan
has been excluding jail was talking
about marginalization an exclusion Sudan
has been defined as an Islamic art state
that is the h 2 o suta if you if you
don't block that category you better go
and find yourself a country that you can
go to especially yours if you are having
African age doesn't and you look like
meet up you need to find a country where
you can go to and this is the cause of
the problem that is why we have been
fighting one another because if you can
find this country where we are now us it
is a wide Catholic public definitely you
will have a problem with partisans and
Lutheran's and other religions also but
if it's more group of people decided in
define country their own narrow way then
it's going to be a problem which is why
we managed to fight one another for a
long time in that agreement was made to
address two issues because we have have
been having a lot of problems it's done
we say okay let us address this problem
sir by transforming Sudan into a better
student for all of us so that is
objective number one in agreement they
dodged transforms you done so that
should I can belongs to all of us so
that the unity of student can be
attractive the second objective was
resilient for the southerners to be
asked through a referendum in 2011
January if they are going to be a part
of Sudan oh this is Sita
your own country there are formalities
and so the two managers now we have been
having to continue with our brilliant
implemented we have left with only nine
months next year january ninth the
people are solid on our board important
i decide the whole point of an
aspiration if they're going to be far as
done or the urgency but before then we
are going to have induction in apple we
are afraid if this election is going to
be feeling that because jailer was
talking about 12 candidates including
one sunday was you four counties
including a woman planning one of the
candidates is somebody who's also
indicted by the ICC he's the current
President of Sudan will he allow himself
to lose the election and Hanover power
to the person who is the current of worn
in action the answer is going to be
known because mr. Campos when he waiting
for him protection so then definitely he
will try to happen or to win the
election by all means liberating so
possibility of relative not be free and
fair is there or will you get that but
before election is very important for us
to monetary so that we avoid our tent
war we have to make sure that it's free
and fair it is monitored party nice not
have access not just volume monitoring
it but have taxes to all the polling
centers the second one is the border
between the North and South has to be
demarcated before next year 2011 it is
very important that our areas that we
did not read up on yet but I think it is
very important to not get the body
because you can if you can recall
situation between it'll be an area it is
because of the border and it is not yet
solved the third one is there a friend
of itself it is very important for us
others like myself and others because we
can compromise election but we will
never compromise that from them because
this is what we have been fighting for
and we want to decide our future is
referendum it has to be free and fair
and has to be conducted on time
generally ninth 2011 extending it for a
day or two is basically activism war
solvents release the last one is the
post 2011 arrangement what can we do
because as of now we own a diamond club
and the unity of Sudan will never be
made a tractive this all this so many
people want to Sudan and they're done
their research and in surveys and they
came that they went to the villages
asking local people from the South what
is your opinion about that random are
you going to vote for separation or
unity of incident it is very ok
yes protector ninety-eight percent of
the people of South Sudan argota for
separation in next year so this is
coming it is not just a dream it is the
reality it is coming what we needed to
do is to accept the reality of the
situation and how you can deal with it
so next year so that is going to be two
countries and we need to dis accept the
reality it's oppressive and avoiding a
return to war so that we can have a soft
landing in 2011 yes some people this is
final thank you people are talking about
the capability of the government songs
granted up in itself in 2011 people are
actually even prejudging us that your
pre failed state already go these your
security corruption and governance and
all of those issues our argument has
been like yes we need some support need
some help if you can do a comparison
between us and his team or when they
were transitioned to stay home there was
some technical advisors given to them
more than 5,000 technical advisors the
organism to help them transition if we
stay hood but if you look at it in
solitude and now we have only 150 people
150 knots out so at a huge gap so we
need more people to help us capacity can
be built I'm sure corruption is
everywhere but we are having the
political will to help in reducing
Oracle getting rid of currency sure you
will not get rid of it but is a
difficult thing you have to deal with
even here in this country the issue of
insecurity years we are dealing with it
but I think generally what we needed to
do see happening is our capacity to be
to be built so that we can effectively
covered and this can be addressed but
the future of the people cannot be
prevented because there are some
criticism and also other issues and I
use a lot of myself as an example
finally
you know in 1985 with you if you happen
to me to meet me I don't know how you
cease I don't even know how to speak
English I don't even know how to ride my
own language I was in the bushes of
solids we run fighting as a young boy
but there was some commanders who were a
bit higher in educating and when you
stop fighting there won't tell me
Ezekiel this is a this is B this is C
this is these until we continue
educating ourselves the bushes are the
trees until now i can edit communicate
to your English what I'm trying to say
the capacity of people can be built they
build my capacity in the bushes of
southern Sudan and here you know I can
communicate with you you cannot deny the
future of the people because they don't
have the capacity you can
well thank you very much David
appreciate it it's always wonderful to
be to come into a place and see cookies
and coffee I mean I this this is great
so thank you to the organizers for
inviting me and thank you for this
opportunity to learn from the diaspora
community and to be with my good friends
Jerry and Ezekiel this is the valuable
form and I really look forward to
learning from you to listen to what you
have to say and then taking this back
and putting this into practice in what
we do you know you probably know that
last October that we released our
strategy and let me just quickly go over
some of the aspects of our strategy
first we seek a definitive end to the
conflict and to the grocery rights
abuses and to the mass atrocities and
genocide that took place we want to make
sure that any political agreement in
fact as all political agreements are
implemented and that they're inclusive
and totally comprehensive and that the
people on the ground see a difference in
their daily lives we want to make sure
that if we accomplish that that we never
go back to the situation of the people
who've had to endure and it's incredible
that they still live in IDP camps but
they still don't have the human rights
that they deserve and they still don't
have a future that they can control this
has to change and we can never go back
to the situation that we exist today and
existed before if we indeed can end this
conflict and indeed we can change the
conditions on the ground the second
aspect is the comprehensive peace
agreement ezekiel's talked about it it's
a key tenant of what we're doing it's so
important we want to make sure that that
comprehensive peace agreement or what we
call the CPA is fully implemented and in
the next couple years we're going to
have to work very hard as a zico said
it's not only building the capacity
but it's getting through these
milestones the first milestone is coming
up in less than a month and that's the
elections and the second one that is
probably the most important is that
referendum that Ezekiel talked about so
passionately that will take place on the
ninth of January in 2011 the third
aspect has to do with terrorism you know
Sudan once was a haven of terrorists
sama bin Laden lived there we want to
make sure that it never again becomes a
home or a haven for terrorists or
terrorist groups and we're working very
hard to make sure that never happens
again let me speak a little bit about
what we've been doing in the last couple
weeks in the last couple months you know
Darfur has been a huge priority for us
as has the south and in recent weeks
there's been some significant
breakthroughs on the Darfur e side first
there was an accord that was signed on
the fifteenth of January between Chad
and Sudan and we think that was very
important because they were approached
ball and that confidence building that
comes from border monitoring an exchange
of military and intelligence and
political views and activities I think
that will help a lot and certainly
what's happened in terms of jem and the
cutting off of the gem enforcing the gym
to go to Doha is going to be absolutely
critical to bringing peace of the
strategic level what we really need to
do then is to make sure that that piece
that happens that piece that will stop
people from being displaced turns into
changes in individual security both
Jerry and Ezekiel talk about it but we
have to make sure that people can go
outside without fear of gender-based
violence that they don't worry about
losing their personal possessions and
they don't worry about being taken into
a situation where there's no rule of law
there's no pattern of justice and order
and where they can't defend themselves
in a way that's fair and free those
things have to change there's also been
some significant progress in Doha as
many of you know there was an agreement
that was signed
a little while ago with the gym and the
government of Sudan that agreement
talked about prisoner releases that
talked about a ceasefire and it talked
about power sharing just a few days ago
three days ago to be exact on 18th there
was another agreement signed with the
liberation justice movement and that's a
group that's come together with forces
of rebel forces and movements that came
out of Tripoli and some that we've been
able to organize and help unify and
addis there's still three groups that
are not part of this but we're working
with them to either join jen where
they'll JM so that there can be a
ceasefire that affects all rebel
movements in Darfur this is the this
will be the foundation but then and I'd
like to answer these kind of questions
in the Q&A but at some point Jerry is
exactly right because the census wasn't
participated in fully because there was
conflict because people were afraid to
register or or become part of the IDP
community because they thought they
would lose their land and hakuna is so
important that that many people did not
participate in the census or the
registration and because Sudanese law
says you cannot participate in the
election or stand for election if you're
part of an armed movement that excluded
most of the rebels and most of the
natural leaders that were in Darfur so
that's why this wealth sharing piece is
so important and it's so important that
we get this right that there's
representation is to change the
constitution so seats are added for
Darfur in the National Assembly in the
local assemblies so as these rebel
groups demobilize and become political
forces that they have a voice in the
government so they can represent their
people it's also important that as peace
comes and we hope it does and as people
are able to move back to their lands and
we hope they can
in a way that's voluntary a way that
they can move with compassion and human
rights and a way they can move so that
it's a permanent move and we're land
reform and compensation or part of it if
that happens there probably needs to be
another census and there needs to be
another redistricting and there needs to
be another election and so we're pushing
to make sure that that happens in about
two to three years or contingent upon
when people can move back to their lands
and it's interesting that not all want
to move back to our lives many of these
people have lived up to six maybe even
seven years in IDP camps if you haven't
sort of used to living in an urban
setting and we want to make sure that it
they get a choice if they want to live
in an urban setting or peri-urban
setting that they can do it in a
sustainable way and if they want to move
back to their lands in a community that
that's done or if they want to move back
to individual villages that they have
that option these are things that we're
working for and we're incorporating into
the Doha peace process they will be this
ceasefire prisoner release and well
sharing that's signed with the rebel
groups and then there has to be an
implementation agreement an agreement
that works on compensation on the well
sharing development making sure that
Darfur gets its fair share of the budget
and it has to include land reform that
we've talked about and certainly
accountability justice has to be there
because they'll never be peace in Darfur
if there's not accountability and
justice if the wrongs of the past are
not write it in a way that's credible
and where the people themselves get a
chance to have in their own minds a
justice about things that have happened
in the past and a hope that the future
would better you know that was also
brought up unfortunately in the last
couple weeks there has been a military
offensive against the last holdout of
SLA in jebel marra and even though this
group had not signed a ceasefire this
offensive has resulted in casualties
displacement and it is actually forced
polarization Gohan made things a lot
more difficult I had strongly condemned
this through the State Department public
affairs releases and in my meetings with
senior officials this has to stop we do
believe that the agreement made with ljm
maybe a foundation from penis fix this
but the jebel marra is something that is
uh it weighs heavy on us and something
that we're working very hard to fix the
cpa as i said is a very important
component of our strategy and those
elections that will happen hopefully
between the eleventh and thirteenth
maybe have a little bit of slip because
the logistics are pretty important these
legislative and executive elections in
my view are a milestone for the cpa they
are an important step toward political
transformation because this balloting is
the first time in 24 years that we've
been able to have a competitive
multi-party election you know in the
environment still remains problematic on
both the north and the south and the
east and the West but we're doing our
best to make sure these elections are
the most free the most fair and the most
credible as they can be because the
Sudanese people need to be able to
express their individual and collective
will in a way that allows their voice to
be heard and there will become
implemented in a way that reflects their
views it's also important that the
process works because it's the same
process in many ways that will be used
to the referendum and certainly as
Ezekiel said we want that to happen on
time and we want that to be credible I
can't think of anything much worse than
having us look back on the referendum on
the tenth and say that was incredible we
have to make sure that the democratic
process that the things like voter
education and voter registration
transparency and security and everything
that goes to make it an election
credible are learned and implemented now
in this election so that we can do our
very best to make sure the South has
every opportunity to have a credible
referendum you know according to then
national election commission 16 million
over 16 million of the approximately 20
million eligible voters registered I
don't know what percent was was illegal
or unfair that's a whole lot four-fifths
of the population registered to vote in
this first election that tells me that
the people of Sudan want to use the
ballot instead of the bullet that has
been used for eighty percent of their
independence that tells me that people
want to express their will and want to
get involved in the political
transformation process in fact as it's
been demonstrated again as as you
pointed out that how the 12 candidates
one is a woman another is Mahdi from who
is the last democratically elected
presidents event there are more than
16,000 people who have decided to run
for the 1841 a legislative seats
twenty-five percent of them are mandated
the beginning there are 72 parties now
represented in this election that's
pretty cool and what we want to make
sure is that out of this foundation that
we work so hard using international
monitors the Carter Center and efforts
that we're all doing in addition to
pressures on the National Election
Commission and on parties north and
south we want to make sure that this is
as free and this fair as possible and
it's really interesting to things like
SMS are become
mean factors that can be used to
identify problem areas I think there's a
good chance that we've started
democratization and political
transformations are then we've seen it
happen in other countries and we hope
that it continues because it's the
process that is what we're aiming for
we're not supporting one party or the
other and in many cases it's not the
outcome that is what we're trying to
achieve we're trying to make sure that
we have a legislative assembly that's
elected because this next year will be a
year of transition where we'll need
legislators that represent to the degree
possible the will of the Sudanese people
your role is so very important and i'm
here today even though i was slept much
in the last couple days and have been
involved a lot of trouble because i want
to hear what you have to say the
diaspora community Save Darfur and other
people that they care passionately about
what happens in Sudan are so important
to us your views your history your
understanding is what we need to be able
to move forward in a clear way so i look
forward to listening to you tonight but
more than that i look forward to
continuing this relationship we've tried
very hard to reach out to the diaspora
community through listening events and I
will work harder and you have my
commitment to make more outreach and
more communication possible because it's
that important and I want to hear from
you so thank you very much I look
forward to your questions and
okay thank you very much speakers and
Jerry and the field and generation thank
you so much for your presentations and
now we will hear from Laura bed and Nia
Bhanumati with the Diaspora
recommendations and comments with
evening everybody I thank all of you for
taking the time to come here and
especial stands to pay scale coalition
for their form and I was able to decide
my colleague gear power for joining us
here and special Sam to the US special
envoy to come here to participate and
listen and share with us so we're
standing here today on behalf of my
sisters and brothers Sudanese diaspora
from South Sudan decor and other part of
Sudan in particular to present here a
priest recommendation that they made
after our long day discussion the first
is the engaging the genuine Jasper that
that they can I can express the
legitimate concern of their people on
the ground the second one is the older
participants they have expressed a great
concern about the US policy towards done
and number one in varied is nah it's not
transparent it's not consistent all Carl
gnostics em this also the consensus
among the participant that the conflict
in dark hole and in South Sudan both are
created and perpetrated by the span Rick
begin and they should be held
accountable and the United States should
put more pressure on the stand
government
not not to trade of that they can only
solve one conflict at a time they should
be for the carnival to solve to solve
both of the complexes turn away and
there is a grave concern among the
participant about security situation in
their fall in particular and in south
sudan and in other part of sudan and so
also there is a concern about the you
name it they are not effective and they
need to be strange scene and then minded
need to be upgraded so that they can
ensure the protection of the civilians
the concerning justice and
accountability the participant believes
at the US as a country ruled by the
supremacy of law should were support or
step up the support for the justice and
accountability to allow justice to be
served for the victim of genocide in
that court and the last in my part is
people have a lot of concern about the
process that is ongoing in do have
because we are skeptical about the
fashion piece and any piece in order to
be sustainable need to address the root
causes of the conflict and to be
inclusive
so I joined a mountain and acknowledging
and thanking everybody who has come here
today I can't I won't go through the
list and order in the interest of time
but I will continue with our
recommendations that resulted from our
discussions among the Diaspora so a next
recommendation is that in light of the
historical situation of the Sudan we
encourage the US policymakers to promote
and support investments in education and
capacity building in the Sudan targeted
especially toward the marginalized
communities southern Sudan and Darfur
ticular the next recommendation that we
derived is we encourage the United
States to support the voluntary and safe
return and I emphasize voluntary and
safety returned to secure villages of
origin in particular we urge the United
States to use its influence and position
of the United Nations to advocate for
stronger UN protection of civilians we
also in this regard and read in regard
to return home we oppose we urge the
United States policymakers to oppose
model villages and ethnic resettlement
of different ethnicities especially as
allegedly occurring in door for the next
recommendation is that we and we're glad
to apart general mention this commitment
but we will reiterate here we urged the
United States to commit to genuine good
faith implementation of the CPR the
comprehensive peace agreement between
the government central government and
the southern Sudan Sudan People's
Liberation Movement and and in that
regard to in general support the
aspirations of the people of southern
Sudan in regards to the fore we urged
the United States to support a genuine
sighs the word genuine peace process and
the aspirations of the people of Darfur
in this regard we have urged the United
States policymakers to oppose the
amendment sham piece gem and force peace
processes that are not genuine and that
are not true to the aspirations of the
people of Darfur and finally and
probably perhaps most importantly from
human perspective is we urge the United
States to condition its Sudanese policy
at City its policy toward sedan on
genuine improvement of human rights
situation in Darfur and southern Sudan
in particular but in all the Sudan and
finally we thank you for your efforts
today generals and your ongoing efforts
I hope that we have an opportunity to
discuss some of these issues in more
detail but I listened very carefully to
what you both have said and I will tell
you that I agree with many of your
concerns and mostly concerns in and I
will do my best to make sure that we're
responsive and that we do end up with a
piece that is for the people in Sudan by
the people who've been and it will
result in a future that's writer for the
next generation Sudanese as you know
that our goal really has been to allow
the people themselves to make the
decisions and the agreements as Ezekiel
tell you we have tried to facilitate but
we've not tried to force and that's what
we're trying to do even in Doha to make
sure that they rebel people and that
Sudanese government that they can an
opportunity to negotiate in the
tri-level talks we've tried to do the
same to make sure that that we create an
environment but we don't live there we
just want to make sure that the people
themselves can come up with agreements
that are lasting and accommodating to
their needs and so I take your points
very carefully we will go back and
incorporate them into our invitation
plan to degree we can and in some of
those areas where where I can give you
an update and the question answer period
I hope we can but I take very sincerely
what you've said and I've learned from
it and I appreciate the expressions and
we'll do our very best to make sure that
when we come back here a year from now
that you won't have to bring up those
issues again but you'll be able to look
back and see that it is last year we've
been able to take those issues that you
brought up today and turn them into
implementation and a piece that
satisfies the requirements of the people
of southern should end of their floor of
Sudan and
region so thank you very much bring them
up thank you good evening anyone who
wishes to pose a question to the general
please write it on your note cards and
some of our helpful staff here will come
around and get it you good folks didn't
come here tonight to listen to me talk
so I'll just stall very briefly and
thank again everyone for coming here
tonight especially the ice para leaders
and thank everyone for the honor of
being able to participate in this
sir
I was just give it a little difficult
think the majority of the initial
questions have come in again if you have
any other ones just please hold them up
in there and someone will collect I will
start with some of the questions that
were already submitted well the peace
talks continue in Doha the sudan
government dropped bombs to burn down
villages in the east of jebel marra
accordingly people fled their burnt
homes leaving victims and belongings as
the issue breaching the ceasefire been
addressed and how would that hurt the
peace process yeah luda to before there
was actually not a ceasefire del moro a
current peace rot See's far but there
was an old ceasefire so we have taken it
as a breach of the old ceasefire we
believe that it was an offensive action
that it was not a defensive action so
there was really no justification at all
for the activities that took place on
jebel marra so that's why we have
condemned it forcefully that's why the
State Department's condenser for slay
the Obama administration is condemned it
forcefully and we continue to pass that
message on it is very true that this
happened it is also very true that that
will continue to put pressure on the
government to allow the situation to
return to normal as fast as possible to
allow the people to return to their
homes and let the NGOs back in and let's
try to get this place recovered as fast
we can but we continue to condemn that
action and not only job tomorrow but
anywhere else that military activities
would take place in an offensive met
nation in fact is now that all the peace
agreements have been signed there should
not be any kind of military activity
offensive or defensive because there's
really nobody fighting anymore and so
we're really putting a lot of pressure
on the government to stabilize and we're
putting pressure on the rebel groups to
demobilize and we hope that all the
fighting
that we've seen over the past seven
years stops Thank You general crash no
you have two questions relating to the
ICC indictment of President Bashir first
Bashir is an indicted war criminal what
impact does this have on the u.s. Sudan
relationship and related to that when
you speak of justice and accountability
does that mean the rest of President
Bashir we know that Bashir is going to
have to come to justice it's very clear
I've said on public television in
Khartoum that President Bashir needs to
be responsive to the ICC and we continue
to push that it's a position of our
government and we'll continue to make
sure that President Bashir comes to
justice and other people that are
associated with the crimes that took
place in Darfur and in southern Sudan
are brought to justice there's nothing
that changes there in fact as this
election won't change anything President
Bashir is in a city and president who is
indicted by the ICC if he wins this
election he'll be a sitting president
who was indicted by the ICC it will not
give him any legitimacy or credibility
but that said we're continue to have to
negotiate many different agreements
we've been negotiating I had never met
President Bashir I've never been in the
same room with President Bashar I've
never talked to President Bashir on the
telephone I've never written them an
email I don't have any communication
whatsoever with President Bashir
directly but the only way that we were
able to bring a solution to Darfur when
the 13 NGOs were kicked out was to have
frank honest dialogue with the
government of sudan we were coming up on
rainy season we lost somewhere in some
places sixty-five percent other places
as high as eighty five percent the
capability to provide food water
sanitation and health
here it was very important that to save
lives we had to talk to the government
of cartoon to be able to bring in more
NGOs new and used to be able to fix the
situation is happening in Darfur it
required that I had one foot in Darfur
and the other foot not doomed as we
started to implement a CPA the situation
was the same it would have been fun to
be able to do it all from Juba but we
can't we had to have one foot in car to
manila and Juba when it came to work in
the proxy war between Chad and Sudan it
had been fun to stay a ninja Mina but we
couldn't we had to have one foot Ninja
mean and one foot in Hutton my point is
to be able to come up with the
agreements to be able to come up with
arrangements to facilitate peace in to
save lives there was no option but to
talk with the government of Khartoum and
we continue to do then but it doesn't
mean that Bashir will be let off the
hook it doesn't mean that the ICC
indictment will be brushed away we
expect all this to happen in time but
there's a whole lot of things that we're
working on and the priority is to make
sure that we get a definitive end to the
fighting in Darfur a restoration of
human rights that we get full
implementation of the cpa the results in
a referendum where the people of the
South can have the opportunity to
express their free will on the 9th of
January when these things are
accomplished and if we can do at the
same time work the Bashir issue but our
priorities are making sure that we get
those things done and then we'll make
sure that President Bashar is brought to
justice
if the coming elections are not free and
fair what effect will this have on US
government relations with the Sudanese
government we're working very hard to
make sure they will be as free and as
fair as possible I understand that it is
almost impossible to have an election
that's free and fair incredible in a
country that hasn't had a democratic
tradition it's almost impossible to have
that kind of alec's in a country that
has not had election for 24 years where
there's generations who have never voted
and then you put on top of that that in
some places it's as low as 10 percent on
a good place it's around twenty percent
of the people are literate when you add
all this together it makes voter
education very tough so I understand
it's going to be very difficult to have
an election that's free and fair but we
need to have an election that is as
credible as possible as free as possible
and as fair as possible so that the will
of the people is expressed in a way that
that they are listened to and in a way
that makes a difference in their lives
over the next couple of years that's
what we're trying to achieve and we know
it's going to be tough we know there's
going to be problems we've already seen
election violence in the south we've
already seen freedoms taken away
freedoms of assembly freedoms of
expression freedom of the press through
it throughout surveillance and we
continue to be concerned about these and
we continue to do action as much as we
can to make sure that the freedoms that
people deserve the freedoms that really
represent political transformation
democratization are implemented in a way
that sticks that's what we're trying to
achieve I don't think we're going to get
it in one election I think it's going to
take time but I think just the same way
we watched in the Green Revolution and
the orange revolution and some of the
other reference revolutions we saw in
Eastern Europe I think it's going to
take us some time but when people find
out that they can make a difference in
there
through the ballot through the
democratic process through
representation I think this is
unstoppable and what we need to do is
continue to create the atmosphere where
this kind of transformation can take
place and that's what we're trying to do
thank you have two related questions
first specifically what is the United
States doing to ensure fair elections
give feuding groups to negotiate to get
people to register get rid of terrorists
I know you verbally condemn negative
actions but what leverage does the
United States have related to that what
is the United States doing to bring
coordination to international efforts in
Sudan I'll do the last one first then
we'll cover the first question number we
believe that the international support
has to be there and it has to be strong
you know this government has has made
staying in power possible because of
segregating and marginalizing and that
kind of thing and in many cases the
international community has done that to
ourselves Jerry talked about the
proliferation of people that are working
on these issues within Becky and man
Curren and Ibrahim jubril bussola au and
again the u.s. what we've tried to do is
bring together the international
community in a coordinated way we
started with what we call the e6 which
is the envoys from the five nations of
the Security Council France China Russia
UK us and we put in the EU also so the
six of us get together very on a
frequent basis we just met in Kigali we
also met in Doha so in the last four or
five weeks we've met two times a person
that we continue to meet on email that's
a very important group because they
reach back into the US are into the
United Nations Security Council the
other group is the troika it is a group
of Nations three of us the Norway US UK
and this troika was very useful in
helping birth the CPA in 2005 and in
navassa and the troika continues to be
important Norway has skills in terms of
oil and helping bring transparency to
the oil situation and we're going to
work together to make sure that the full
implementation is supported by the
international community that that group
this started six seven years ago that
work very closely with the negotiation
process we need it to be strong again to
make sure that the the South has every
opportunity to be birthed in a way that
is not as Ezekiel said that we redouble
our efforts we're putting together a
conference to bring ministers of
development together not to raise more
funds but to build a program to figure
out how to build capacity so we can
absorb more funds I don't think this is
a fun day sure right now it's making
sure that we're all going the same way
same day so that China doesn't build a
road 100 miles long and US doesn't build
a road 100 miles long next to it and the
next person next to we want to build a
road that's 500 miles along by linking
these together and linking railroad
tracks and that's why last week I went
to the Minister of Trade and Kenyan I
said what's your plans to put one point
oh four gauge up to look at Tokyo and on
into Sudan I've met with the ministers
of Trade and Development in Rwanda and
in Uganda to figure out how the puck
watch a rule gulu connection can fit up
with Juba we're also talking to other
international partners to figure out how
we can get a railroad track in to the
oil areas to get into areas where we're
thinking about agribusiness and
development and echo tourism so we can
move supplies and infrastructure all
these things have to happen if we're
going to solve the security issue cell
telephones is probably a big thing you
know so people can communicate so we
don't show up three days
after hundreds of people were killed but
we're able to figure out ahead of time
where the conflict is in ruin and get
conflict mitigators out there they can
make a difference before it's too late
all these things is going to take
everybody working together and that's
why we're working together in the
international community to build these
coalition's to work together not to
force solutions on the sudanese but to
work with the sudanese to make sure that
when they ask for capability for
security or for economics or for social
infrastructure that we're able to come
up with solutions that we can work on
together we don't need pound with six
boreholes when the town 50 miles down
the road has none we need to start
courting our efforts a lot better in the
social area in the health care and and
so that's what we're trying to do that's
the International help but the probably
the most important help is that the
regional level and we got to work very
hard to make sure that that the
countries of eagan ethiopia and kenya
and uganda and that chad the development
that happens there on eastern chad
spills over and is connected to what's
happening in Darfur we may need to make
sure that Libya and Egypt are part of
the solutions and are part of a problem
we need to make sure that Doha is value
added to the peace process but I gotta
tell you the most important thing is the
people themselves none of this will work
unless we can come up with a situation
where the Sudanese talk with student
visa come up with answers where the
local chieftains can figure out how to
get the mystery and Dinka to work
together so the mystery of cows can come
down and get some water and we have to
work together to make sure that the
newer and the should look and the Dinkas
can figure out how to solve those
problems of cattle rustling of the rest
of it this isn't about America fixin or
UK or anybody else this is facilitating
and helping those folks who live in the
country to come up with solutions and
that's what we're trying to do we're
trying to facilitate because we know
that the longest border between the two
countries that will probably exist in
the ninth of july two thousand eleven is
that border between those two countries
and the other nine countries are
significantly important and we all have
to work together and make sure that
everybody can live together in peace and
that the prosperity is what happens in
Subban your the question was about what
now that i've gone solo on this one I
know is important us leverage we don't
have any leverage I got to tell you the
only leverage we have is the leverage we
get by the Sudanese wanting us dead
leverage for 20 years we've been
applying pressures and what have we
gotten the only thing that's making a
difference right now and I haven't
promised ever to remove one single
section I haven't promised to take Sudan
off the state-sponsored terrorism list I
haven't promised anything but we've made
a heck of a lot of progress because the
Sudanese themselves want to make a
difference I believe and I believe that
if we can facilitate this desire for
peace if we can facilitate the desire
for prosperity if we can facilitate the
desire to have the next generation
Sudanese have a brighter and better
future then that's what's going to make
a difference threatening no-fly zones
which in my view are silly threatening
to mine the harbors which are active
Wars threatening to do a lot of the
other things that we call for are not
going to bring about lasting peace
lasting peace is going to happen when
people sit down at the negotiating table
and work it out where wrongs are righted
order wealth is distributed fairly where
resources are managed effectively and
what problems are work through in a
civil way
as opposed to going back to war that's
what we're trying to achieve we have no
leverage we really have no pressure it's
up to the Sudanese to do this and we
need to support their efforts in every
way we can because it's only when they
themselves make a difference in their
lives that it will be lasting it's just
like with our kids we can draw lines
down the middle the room we can do all
this other stuff but until they decide
they want to get along it's going to be
pretty hard to force it so my view is
we're working very hard we're applying
as much pressure as we can in the
international community with the United
States and we'll see what we can to
facilitate an environment where the
Sudanese themselves can come up with a
solution that they need to add a secure
in a better future what is the US policy
to increase access for NGOs to rest
Sudan including areas in the east and
north as well as don't form a genocide
question because it's huge big problem
my solution is this if you take a look
at jebel marra where it's it's it's it's
in a triangle between yalla fasher and
janina if we started getting UNAMID to
patrol that area those roads to
constantly be moving between fashion
yalla and janina to put in their camps
not in the cities but along those routes
if we can get that area where fifty
percent of the Darfur is live in that
ten percent of the triangle if that
could become secure in the next month or
two if we could start development in
there so that those oranges could be
grown and exported so that people could
move freely so the NGOs wouldn't be
sitting inside those little towns afraid
that their cars are going to be
but they could get out and start moving
around not only to the fur but to the
Arabs and to everybody that lives there
start bringing development at the social
level at the economic level we can start
thinking about job creation and wealth
creation what are we going to do when
2.7 million people decide they want to
leave the camps we're going to have to
have a whole system of producing wealth
and we're looking at different options
now but this is something that's going
to be very very tough we have been in a
situation now that we have what i call
sustained relief and we need to switch
that to sustainable development where
Darfur and X number of yours will be
able to stand on its feet and where
people will be able to go out and earn a
living and have a future if we're doing
what we're continuing to do is going to
be very very difficult I agree totally
about the model villages or these force
homes that's not going to work but it's
not going to work either to send all
these people home and have fights over
resources over water over crazy over
farms we're gonna have to think through
this really hard really hard and we need
to start thinking about how we're going
to put magnets out there that get people
to go back in a way that's safe and
secure voluntary and we're going to have
to think about those who want to stay in
the urban environment how we build
communities that are sustainable and
that's why for me it's not just about
security and haven't UNAMID do that it's
about taking this discussion is going on
in Doha about compensation and hooking
that in with this plan because when we
think about his compensation for the
individual or for the community is it a
cow
or is it cash is it a house or is it
some or a horse what are we doing but if
we put everything together into a big
strategic plan it may work especially
when you start thinking about how does
the land reform not negotiated in Doha
but how does land reform fit into this
equation and how does the budget and
well Sharon fit into this budget of
Darfur to sustain these things if we
build a whole bunch of schools and
Americans keep sending money over there
to sustain it that's silly it's got to
be absorbed by the Ministry of Health
and Ministry of Education and security
forces this is horn and right now our
tendency is just to do everything for
them it's not going to work we're going
to have to create an environment where
they can make the decisions about their
future and where we help them and enable
that to the maximum extent by building
capacity by giving advice technical
advice on on value crops and value chain
and how you export and hire earn capital
this is going to be very tough but we
have to do it we have no option but to
succeed failure cannot be an option or
we'll be right back to where we are
today we have a stack of many excellent
questions down here but we are beginning
to encroach on our time so we're going
to try to generalize to just two more
and buy two more I mean these are very
related so I'm not counting them
separately what penalties are sanctions
are in effect today against the
government members collectively and
individually do you think that more
should be imposed and related to that
general gracian strongly condemning the
attack I'm Jeff Amara is not enough what
consequences were applied to the NCP let
me talk about the sanctions first
there are sanctions against the
government and against individuals and
the one problem about sanctions after
the uniform lien forced let me just tell
you about the experience I had a Kaname
you need to know about the cano no sugar
factory I went down there and there was
a big pile of yellow hoax old equipment
and it all said caterpillar owner it was
another big pile of green folks tractors
harvesting equipment and all said John
Deere on it as about run over by Red
mercy Ferguson and has about run over by
another thing that was made in India it
doesn't do much good if we stop selling
our equipment and other people sell
theirs we didn't sell six million
dollars worth of harvesting equipment or
crushers for the sugar cane but the
French did for sanctions to work they
have to be uniformly applied and it's
not happening right now so the effect of
our sanctions is is not that much where
there's a profit for other people to
gain from it so sanctions on the
industries and sanctions on other
economic things where there's a profit
motive for other people to break these
sanctions our sanctions are doing very
good job it is interesting where our
sanctions are working the best are
against the Sudanese people right now
you cannot import or download any kind
of educational programs into them you
can't get norton utilities you can't
take online training because we've done
such an effective job at sanctioning
software and the Internet I'm trying to
help the people in the east as many of
you know the Eastern peace agreements
very fragile the bench of people on
other people around port Subban are
living in conditions that in many ways
worse than
for but it's in the north and sanction
that we can't help them so what's
happening is is that in many cases that
sanctions that we have imposed are
hurting the very people are trying to
help it's very difficult to get a know
fact licensed to do the kinds of things
that we want to do and need to do in
addition to that these sanctions have
created an atmosphere of just same note
the presumption that you cannot get
anything approved so even though
southern Sudan and Darfur are free from
many of the restrictions nobody's apply
and in fact is we're allowed to have
medical equipment some supplies and that
kind of thing sent in even to the north
and nobody's sending it in because
they're afraid to do business with the
north our education accounts are
divesting people are divesting from
everything possible that has to do with
Sudan and the problem is this there's a
perception that if you're in the North
you're bad and evil and in fact is the
perception is is if you're born inside
the su da n you're bad and I got to tell
you those little kids who are three and
five years old they need a future they
need education they need health care
they need water and they need food and
yet we've sanctioned every bit of farm
equipment in the North every bit we're
trying to get a peanut harvester in an
ass organ planner and it's illegal so we
import all the food for Darfur from
America and other places and we spend 13
hundred dollars a ton bringing it into
the country 43 cents on the dollar we
spend 1.9 billion dollars and Zhu Ben
and we waste a lot of it because we're
not bringing in track
and growing this food and what happens
when we stop you all heard about this
thing to teach a guy to fish what we're
doing is we're given fish away and then
someday if we stop that people go hungry
we need to take a good look at our
sanctions and start thinking how do we
do smart sanctions how do we do
sanctions that help the very people were
trying to help and how do we do
sanctions that hurt the regime's were
trying to hurt and right now we think
we're doing a really wonderful job but I
got to tell you honestly or not and I
don't know how to fix this because
there's no space to even bring up the
word sanction in Washington at some
point we're going to have to do this
maybe now is not the time maybe it will
be in the future but we have to start
sure as they thinking about how do we
help the very people we want to help and
how do we make sure those kids even if
they're born in Port Sudan of a future
okay again I apologize for all the
questions we didn't get an opportunity
to here tonight for we're all conference
participants will be the breakfast
tomorrow morning with general Grayson
and I'd like to just very briefly and I
12 to summarize the evening all of us
are familiar with many of the challenges
ahead generation could you identify what
you see some of the largest where I
brought blocks and briefly speak about
how we move past it yeah this is
something that we all have to work on
you know where we're not United in
America on this issue and probably for
very good reasons but at some point we
all have to join the same team and help
sue them and I know there's difference
on tactics I know there's differences
and approaches and that kind of thing
but there's really no difference in what
we're trying to accomplish I don't think
there's anybody in here that is against
a definitive end to the conflict in dark
for an end to gross human rights abuses
an end to the genocide that took place I
don't think anybody's against full
implementation of the cpa
democratization of political reform
transformation I don't think anybody's
against keeping terrorists from using
Sudan but we fight each other this forum
is an excellent forum to start laying
down our gun like techniques and stop
shooting at each other and start uniting
the phone what we have to do I got to
tell you I'm open to all your ideas I
want to learn and listen from the oil
the same way I learn and listen from
ezekiel's team and from the Darfur II
team and I span into the wee hours of
the morning with all the different rebel
groups
we need to unite and stop shooting each
other and start figuring out what's
right and if there's things that we're
doing wrong I want to hear about it and
if there's things that we can do better
I want to hear about it but I got to
tell you that personal attacks against
the Obama administration the personal
attacks against what I I see happen in
my view are not useful we're all working
very hard to ensure a brighter future
for darfur for the south and for the
whole region if it's something that
we're doing wrong that's a matter of
policy then let's hear about it and
let's fix that and this work together I
got to tell you we need to be on the
same team in my view and it's
disappointing to me when I go around and
talk to people and I get a
confrontational kind of stuff and I got
a weird I know we're screwing them you
don't have to tell me where screw them I
understand that and we want to fix that
but I got to tell you we have to really
stop klinken at things that we ought to
be working together on Ezekiel brought
it up a little bit too there's people
saying the south is going to be born as
a feeble state and they shouldn't be
given an opportunity independence in our
view if the will of the people is
carried out an incredible election they
choose independence then we need to be
redoubling our effort is there it's the
same in Darfur we need to work together
as a team and if there's things that are
bad we ought to fix us and the military
we do that privately and if there's
things that are good that are praising
in public
but here in America we do a little bit
officer we hammer in public and destroy
institutions and destroy what we're
trying to do and I thought it's pretty
cool that you said thank you for doing
and I appreciate that because that's
probably the first time I've heard that
I've been the Envoy I celebrated my
anniversary on the 18th I've never heard
one bit of thanks from the opposite
community
I don't need it but it'd sure be nice to
know that we're working the same issues
and I'd certainly like to be on the same
team as advocacy community because in my
view this is what America is doing to
fix and save sue then it's not about
what the Obama administration is doing
it's not about what me and the envoy is
trying to do it's about what our country
is trying to do along with the rest of
the international community of regional
partners to make sure that Sudan has a
successful future and I know you
probably didn't come here to hear me
whine about this but um I would really
want to listen to you tomorrow and
continue to build a team and continue to
work together on these issues and up and
not apart so thank you very much
okay well thank you everybody and
especially generation for you well thank
you for your efforts to but thank you
for your reference here tonight and we
included the event in our in our
conference packet we included in
Savannah policy statement and President
Obama's statement so i can't i'm not
speaking for the Diaspora i'm saying
that we're trying to understand how
things can advance that's that's the
project here so again thank you very
much to look forward to your appearance
tomorrow and say thank you to Catherine
your assistant for a good communication
and arranging your visit and thank
everybody who gained you Jerry wish you
continued success in your new venture
and Natasha too and there's some of the
people to say something too but class
dismissed